he brought up the wayfarer thing and the
adrenochrome thing what are your
thoughts on that so wayfair not true uh
never happened um started in like a
sub-threaded of a sub-threat of reddit
where most most of the things of the
world start how do you know it's not
true though like why give us some some
one we traced it all the way back to um
it was a it was a pricing uh algorithm
issue right like as an example my
coinbase account the other day said that
my account was worth like 31 million
dollars nice right hey thanks a lot
coinbase for that uh
but did it rename your account the name
of a girl who went missing six weeks ago
um we how much was in your account for
the record uh
not 31 million you must you must work
for maxwell yeah
um
not your little black people not 31
million okay the the point is um yeah so
like you're saying wayfair was fake
though yeah we actually placed orders
um like like anytime there's one of
these conspiracy theories um we actually
will go through and like actually go
through the process
let's yeah let's let's figure out what's
weight fair
child sex trafficking fake
totally fake adrenochrome adrenochrome
totally fake like that's explained
yeah so when you drink it
what are the digestive juices in your
stomach due to it i don't know i've
never taken the dream yeah right gerardo
first of all you're not supposed to
drink it you're supposed to drop it into
your yeah exactly now you know no it's
killed
explain this please
the answer is your stomach is one of the
most caustic environments on earth and
it takes care of that stuff that jokes
not yourself drop the mic no no the
typical human stubborn it's one of the
most caustic environments on earth if
you know anything about it what does it
mean
and so anything that goes in your
stomach gets broken down rather rapidly
here's what's happening with conspiracy
theories the
the
human trafficking in america right like
like on here um it says you know
pennsylvania is among the top human
trafficking states in the country they
all are
human trafficking is highly highly
transitory highly transitory and because
of covet a lot of human trafficking has
actually shifted online
why do you think that there has been
such an explosion of only fans
right human traffickers are putting
their girls i mean right it's a business
to them they got to scale that business
you have an unlimited
uh right well we'll ask the phd in the
room what happens when you have an
absolutely unlimited supply because
vulnerable people are the supply right
and you have a limited demand because
again like not everybody is like trying
to find uh you know young young children
to have sex with or even look at
so you have a limited demand so
unlimited supply with a limited demand
you've got a price that's pretty much
bottomed out in the market
and so human traffickers have to do
business at scale so them putting their
their victims on only fans we have
plenty of cases of this that this is
true and this is this happens on about
42 different websites across the country
which we are all over like what on rice
by the way like they they yeah they just
can't avoid the number one website uh
apparently is facebook for this kind of
stuff well it used to be it used to be
better page right like that and then
back
back back
and then finally the government took
back the page down and it was the
primary source of intelligence on the
takedown and back was that you that
we actually moved into their
headquarters afterwards because we build
our empires on the skulls of our enemies
wow did they did backpage know what they
were doing the whole time they
absolutely knew um and
the way i know this is again we've
because
they were going to be craigslist right
they were like a craigslist competitor
we traced this stuff out we actually
posted a job or not a job we posted an
ad for a 16 year old girl we've got this
all on film on camera posted an ad for a
16 year old girl on backpage.com
and it went live uh minutes later with
the age change to 18. no
no no
they actually automated that piece uh
they were that i mean that's how in
depth they were but that's also why they
were charged with human trafficking why
they all pled guilty right the only two
left were are the owners they're super
old and really bad health and so they're
just riding it out but the uh um the
point here is that the major majority of
human trafficking in the united states
right we all want to look at the
epsteins right but let's break down the
epstein case all that was was what
happens
every single day probably within five
miles of this building right here in
almost every major metropolitan area in
the country and increasingly smaller
towns
that that same playbook that exact same
playbook not on that level
but the exact same playbook right you
find somebody who's vulnerable
right young teenage girl most vulnerable
people in the world you start
manipulating them you start pulling them
away from their support network and then
they start getting them hooked on
narcotics and and then their their lives
are their lives are ruined so when we
look at the standard model of human
trafficking
people want to focus on the pizzagates
which isn't real again we've got more
human trafficking data than anybody on
the planet i mean we literally have more
human trafficking data than probably
almost all governments combined i mean
it's what we do and we're really good at
it there's no patterns in any of that
data that would suggest that any of that
is even remotely real like not even not
even the smallest little signal
what people want to focus on is well
there's children being trafficked in the
basement of a
of a pizza parlor
and then they go log on to their only
fans account
and they want to realize that they're
the ones actually feeding money into the
human trafficking system they're the
ones actually participating in it right
they want to go get what they think is
an escort for a bachelor party
but that girl actually um has a baby in
las vegas that our human trafficker is
holding on to
and if she doesn't bring in a thousand
dollars a night he hurts the baby
and so of course she says she wants to
do this because she'll do anything to
protect that child that's a real case
that that we
do okay so i mean that what you just
said there though i mean isn't that the
libertarian argument for legalizing sex
work so because then it can be monitored
and it could be regulated and that's the
whole heidi fleiss argument yeah people
aren't going to stop having you're not
going to make a moral argument that
that's going to force people to stop
having bachelors it's like you said the
war on drugs is winning correct yeah no
so um i don't think uh
i don't think that is uh
it's not a bad argument the libertarian
argument for legalization of
prostitution it's not a bad argument the
problem is that the data just doesn't
back it up because every country that's
ever legalized prostitution has seen a
spike in human trafficking portugal and
amsterdam yeah oh yeah among the biggest
ones the last one the last country that
just did it was uh was germany and now
they're actually trying to reverse the
legalization of prostitution because
they've had such an explosion in human
trafficking correct right you said that
you know pat brought up pennsylvania's
and you're like look it's every state
it's transitory are there certain
countries that's like that's the sex
trafficking capital of the world no it's
in china is it india
it's not nevada right i mean honestly
let's be honest like texas
right because it's at the border you're
saying it's america it
country
well
so let me give you let me tell you how
this works right so
uh where think think of it like the drug
market where the drugs sold
they're sold in the wealthy school
district not in the poor school district
right they're dealt out of the poor
school district sold to the wealthy
school district because that's where the
money is yeah yeah right
money it's the same reason people
who is that the money is the dutch guy
who was abducting girls and like a
reuben and selling them the singing
or something yeah and he'd still be
getting away with it if that girl didn't
die um it's it's exports
right and so so for other countries like
i was just in kiev um helping their law
enforcement with some of their human
trafficking issues
um all the the human trafficking that's
happening over there is primarily
exported out to other countries to
wealthy western european countries and
and and americans right and actually a
lot of chinese increasingly
so when you start when you start looking
at it through that lens most of the most
the trafficking is happening there
people think about things like cambodia
and vietnam and thailand there's a lot
of cultural trafficking that's happening
there so you actually have parents are
trafficking their children that happens
a lot in the united states as well
so when you when you look at when you
look at the trafficking piece like it's
so nuanced and it's so complicated and
there's so many arguments in there on
like the libertarian side and then what
what kind of trafficking we're talking
about predominant form of trafficking in
the world is is labor trafficking right
that's actually the predominant form
even here in the united states i mean
slavery has been pretty popular for a
couple thousand years yeah so we we tend
to look at the we tend to we tend to
focus on the the commercial sex side but
there's labor trafficking there's organ
trafficking um babies being grown in uh
in a country i was just in um
specifically to harvest their organs uh
i mean like like really really horrific
stuff like that those are the things
that we need to be focused on not the
our children being sold in the this is
your day-to-day life seeing the absolute
worst this is what we do
all day we live in hell
10 hours 12 hours a day every day how do
you you're not going to work how do you
not go crazy yeah i'm like how do you
not lose your mind i mean so that this
is my first rodeo at this i mean my my
entire career was you know counter
narcotics and counterterrorism so i mean
i've seen some pretty horrific stuff
i've got 30 uh short tour combat
deployments um and you freaking pick the
pick the stand i've
i've fought there um so
this this is just i mean this is just
the way that god made me um and and and
it's not me i mean i'm
i'm lucky enough that i get to be the
point man on all of this but i have a
team that is absolutely world class so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]